Добрий день, дорогі друзі.
Вітаю вас на уроці
української мови для одинадцятикласників
Моє ім’я Ігор Хворостяний. І я пропоную
вам замислитися над питанням “стиль”.
Що об’єднує всі ці картини?
Це все – про стиль. Чи то стиль у живописі,
в даному випадку маємо стиль авангардизм.
Чи то архітектурний стиль – той чи інакший.
Чи стиль, зрештою, зовнішнього
вигляду людини – одягу.
Чи літературний стиль.
Є красиве визначення, що стиль – це краса.
Є інше, що стиль – це
завжди вибір і відчуття смаку.
Зрештою, можливо, саме ці
критерії і ляжуть сьогодні в основу
під час розгляду уроку «Функціональні
стилі сучасної української мови».
Але перед тим, як дати
визначення поняттю стилю,
я б хотів запропонувати вам
поглянути на кілька текстів.
Їх всього чотири.
Це уривки з книги французького
письменника Ремона Кемо «Вправи зі стилю».
Текст номер один – нейтральний.
Наступний текст передаватиме той самий
зміст. Проте, інакше. Поглянемо на нього.
автобуса, який рухався вгору вулицею
Курсель у напрямку до Шамперрейських воріт.
Зазначений автобус був заповнений,
точніше навіть переповнений
Я не буду зачитувати весь текст,
проте погляньмо на його завершення.
Текст номер три про те саме.
Він перед вами на екрані.
А потім – бачить, місто освободилося,
ну він швиденько і плюх на нього –
і сидить довольний весь із себе.
Німножко пізніше знов бачу
його, їдучи по своїх ділах в автобусі,
він коло вокзалу базарить із якимось
чуваком, таким же прибацаним, як і сам.
А той йому говорить,
тіпа, неплохо тобі було б
пришить ще одну пугвицю осюди
на пальто. Мені б, блін, його заботи!
Той самий текст, але зовсім з іншим добором
мовленнєвих засобів.
І погляньмо на фінальний.
я видрав ґудзика з корінням.
Як бачите, всі чотири тексти передають
за змістом одну й ту саму інформацію:
людина їде в переповненому транспортному
засобі, в неї відривається ґудзик. Все.
Але способи подачі інформації у
всіх чотирьох текстах абсолютно різні.
Ми плавно перейшли до того
визначення, що ж таке “стиль”?
Мовний стиль, а, оскільки всі наші
чотири тексти написані різними стилями:
розмовний суржикоподібний, ви бачили,
ось цей текст ”вже було послє двенацяти”.
він містить ряд таких собі слів
паразитів, зменшеної лексики,
яка межує з ненормативною, часом,
невнормоване використання слів і так далі.
Це – стиль розмовний.
Цей текст – зразок офіційно-ділового стилю,
оскільки ми маємо ряд мовленнєвих кліше,
штампів мовлення, певну
структуру офіційно-ділового листа
зі звертанням головного героя
цього листа і клопотанням-скаргою.
І ось цей текст – яскравий
зразок художнього стилю,
оскільки маємо образне мовлення,
маємо сонет за жанровою формою –
чотирнадцять рядків, пригадайте, будь ласка.
І відповідний добір емоційно
наснажених мовленнєвих засобів.
То що ж таке “стиль”?
Стиль – це сукупність засобів,
вибір яких зумовлюється змістом,
метою та характером висловлювання.
Власне, те, з чого я починав.
Стиль – це завжди вибір.
В тій чи іншій ситуації я добираю із цілого
огрому тих засобів, які є в арсеналі мови,
той чи інший мовленнєвий засіб.
Відповідно, стилістика – це розділ науки
про мову, що вивчає виражальні засоби мови,
такі якості мовлення, як точність,
логічність, образність, доречність.
І, також, наука про функціонування
та використання мови.
Які ж є стилі сучасної
української мови?
Їх основних, принаймні, п’ять.
Перший – це художній.
Художній стиль по суті – це
мова художньої літератури.
Основне призначення і мета цього стилю –
це вплив на почуття та емоції
людей за допомогою художніх образів.
Ознаки характерні:
емоційність, образність, експресивність.
По суті, цей стиль задіює всі
арсенали мовленнєві, які існують у мові,
все словникове багатство мови.
Ці тексти багаті на епітети,
метафори, порівняння, інші тропи.
Можуть використовуватись також
діалектні слова, професійна лексика,
різні типи речень за будовою і
структурою, метою висловлювань і так далі.
Тобто, по суті, досить широкий набір
засобів, якими ми можемо послуговуватися
для досягнення головної мети –
вплив на думки і почуття за
допомогою художніх образів.
Жанри: трагедія, комедія, драма, роман,
повість, оповідання, новела, поема, сонет.
По суті, всі ті жанри літератури,
які ми і вчимо на уроках літератури.
Другий стиль - це
офіційно-діловий стиль.
По суті, це мова ділових паперів.
І основна мета цього стилю – це
регулювання офіційно-ділових відносин.
Цей стиль дуже чітко структурований.
Він складається з окремих
компонентів, які називаються реквізитами.
Вони можуть вживатися
лише в певній послідовності.
Коли ви пишете, наприклад, заяву, ви
не можете її почати з тексту самої заяви:
“Прошу вас зарахувати мене до складу
студентів такого-то університету”. Ні.
Ви маєте вказати адресата,
тобто, кому адресована ця заява,
адресанта – себе самого чи
саму, від кого ця заява надходить
і поставити дату і підпис.
Це лише один простий приклад того,
як ці складові елементи документа
– реквізити, впорядковані в тексті.
Певна послідовність викладу
фактів, гранична чіткість висловлювань.
Офіційно-діловий стиль не
полюбляє двозначність трактувань,
полісемію, тобто, багатозначність.
І стандартизація, про що я вже сказав.
Лексика, здебільшого,
нейтральна; почасти кажуть – суха.
Залежно від того, яку галузь обслуговує
офіційно-діловий стиль, він може містити:
суспільно-політичну, професійно-виробничу,
науково-термінологічну лексику.
Синтаксис цього стилю
характеризується певним порядком слів
і добором мовленнєвих засобів,
текст поділяють, як правило,
на пункти, підпункти і так далі.
Тобто, простіше кажучи, цей стиль
значно регламентований.
Жанри типові: закон, кодекс,
оголошення, розписка, протокол,
виступи на зборах офіційних,
наради, прес-конференції.
Ще один стиль – науковий.
Науковий стиль обслуговує
сферу й потреби науки.
І основне його призначення, на відміну
від художнього і офіційно-ділового –
це виклад наукового матеріалу, фактів.
Точність, логічність, інформативна
насиченість, об’єктивність,
аргументованість – все це є
ознаками наукового стилю.
В науковому стилі досить широко
використовується термінологія
з абстрактним значенням, поширеними
є слова іншомовного походження.
Текст також може розподілятися
за абзацами, пунктами і підпунктами.
До тексту, як правило, введено
діаграми, графіки, таблиці.
Тобто, науковий текст передбачає
використання текстів різних видів і типів.
І типовими жанрами є
дисертація, монографія,
посібник, підручник,
анотація тощо.
Публіцистичний
Ви також можете натрапити на визначення
“стиль засобів масової інформації”
чи ”стиль масової інформації”,
або ”стиль мас-медіа”.
По суті, це все одні й ті ж характеристики
для позначення публіцистичного стилю.
Це різновид мовлення, яким послуговуються
в засобах масової інформації:
на телебаченні, в газетах,
журналах, статтях тощо.
Метою публіцистичного
стилю, на перший погляд,
може скластися думка, що це – інформування.
Проте, як правило, публіцистичний
стиль, або стиль засобів масової інформації
має основною метою вплив.
Досить рідко ми натрапляємо на максимально
об’єктивовані зразки журналістського тексту
чи будь-якого іншого тексту
засобів масової інформації.
Як правило, мета публіцистичного стилю –
сформувати певну громадську думку
чи особисту думку тієї, чи іншої людини.
Популярний чіткий виклад,
оскільки аудиторія, на яку
орієнтується публіцистичний стиль,
надзвичайно широка – це люди з
різними вподобаннями, захопленнями.
Стислість і зрозумілість інформації.
Зараз кажуть, що ніхто не
читає лонгрідів, це нецікаво.
Лонгрід, тобто, мається на
увазі довгий, тривалий текст.
Використання суспільно-політичної лексики.
Цей стиль також досить емоційний.
Він може містити, оскільки він і
покликаний сформувати певну думку,
певні риторичні питання, риторичні оклики,
фігури замовчування:
”І хто ж у цьому винен …”.
Тон мовлення пристрасний, оцінний.
Типові жанри: виступ, нарис,
стаття, памфлет, фейлетон, дискусія.
Розмовний стиль.
Певно, найуживаніший із усіх стилів,
оскільки ми послуговуємося
ним у щоденній нашій практиці.
Це стиль, що обслуговує
будь-яке спілкування людей
як офіційне, так і неофіційне,
їхні побутові потреби.
І основна мета цього стилю –
обмін думками, враженнями,
прохання про допомогу чи можливості
надати цю допомогу, якийсь певний вплив.
Розмовно-побутовий стиль
найменш унормований.
Він допускає використання і
вживання мовленнєвих засобів,
що почасти перебувають, навіть,
поза межею літературної мови.
Суржик, знижена лексика,
порушення літературних норм
у будь-якій із можливих форм;
використання вульгаризмів, жаргонізмів;
часом, спотворення вимови слів і подібне.
Використовується в
абсолютно різних жанрах.
Розмовний стиль може проникати
в будь-який із інших стилів.
Наприклад, коли автор, письменник
створює певний художній образ,
він може надати
характеристику персонажу
саме за допомогою елементів
цього розмовного стилю.
І загальна.
Конструюючи речення, ще раз нагадаю
вкотре про те, що стиль – це вибір.
Тобто, добираючи будь що, створюючи,
наприклад, власне висловлення
на зовнішньому незалежному оцінюванні,
чи створюючи якийсь свій
художній текст в художньому стилі,
пам’ятайте, що добір того чи
іншого мовленнєвого засобу
напряму вплине на
результат вашої діяльності.
Він має бути підпорядкований вашій меті.
Погодьтеся, навряд чи хтось в
розмовному стилі почне звертатися фразами
з офіційно-ділового “Глибокошановний
друже” там, де це недоречно.
У зв’язку з цим, пропоную
проаналізувати чотири речення
і визначити в них стилістичні помилки.
Перше.
Професор під час лекції балакав
про теорії походження людини.
Одразу щось ріже слух.
Мені ріже слух слово “балакав”.
Балакати – це лексема, тобто,
слово з побутового мовлення людини.
Говорили балакали, сіли та й заплакали.
Знаємо таку яскраву приказку.
І коли йдеться про
сферу наукової діяльності,
коли професор виголошує певну лекцію чи
доповідь під час навчання в університеті,
навряд чи він балакатиме.
Він – говоритиме, вестиме
мову, розповідатиме.
Інший приклад.
Шановний Петре, я відчуваю
до тебе глибоку неприязнь,
оскільки ти не дозволив мені сьогодні
списати в тебе контрольну роботу.
Погодьтеся, складно уявити таку
ситуацію в реаліях шкільного класу
зі звертанням до свого
друга, котрий не дав списати,
“Шановний Петре”,
“глибока неприязнь”.
Це явно лексика зовсім з іншого
стилю, з офіційно-ділового певно що.
Третій приклад.
З погляду банальної ерудиції,
не кожен тверезо мислячий індивід
буде купувати
товари низької якості за всі гроші світу.
Очевидно, в побутовому мовленні
використання штампів і наукової,
навіть, науково-популярної,
лексики в межах розмови двох друзів,
які іронізують з приводу дорогої покупки
того чи іншого товару, навряд чи доречно.
І останній приклад.
Я, власне, не планувала, власне,
звертатися сьогодні по допомогу.
Як бачите, тут є хиба у ось
цьому слові-паразиті “власне”.
Пам’ятайте, що надмірність будь у
чому мало кому коли була корисною.
Власне, як і в повторенні одних і тих
самих слів в межах одного речення.
Така невиправдана тавтологія, чи, в
даному випадку, повторення слова “власне”,
шкодить текстові замість
того, щоб його вдосконалювати.
Повправляймося!
Пропоную поміркувати і дати відповідь на
питання: до якого стилю належить уривок?
Правильна відповідь:
“В”, до наукового стилю.
Другий текст.
Уривок з твору Івана Федоровича Драча.
Правильна відповідь на це
питання: “Г”, до художнього.
Третій і останній текст.
Правильна відповідь,
звісно: “А”, до розмовного.
А я чую, як лунає дзвінок,
тому ми мусимо завершувати.
Щиро дякую вам за увагу.
Наступного разу поговоримо
про стилістичне забарвлення
та виражальні можливості фразеологізмів.
До нових зустрічей!